votre note jamie un indécent paul a
alors vous allez me dire que nous avons
pensé parce qu'on a parlé de vous lire
dans la croix bleue talhouët première
raison c'est pas un vrai vainqueur c'est
un vainqueur par opportunisme et jean
pas voter pour quelqu'un qui a la voix
de johnny sont votés pour johnny
hallyday et deuxième raison c'est
bidonné cyril pourquoi c'est bidonné
souvenez vous avant la saison on avait
parlé ici de la communication de m6 sur
les réseaux sociaux
et il avait mis deux candidats en
exergue en évidence le sosie de johnny
hallyday et le couple hasard ac les deux
avec ses doutes quand on sait qu'avant
quelque chose c'est que cette requête
mois sur le couac de la laponie dans la
bande annonce par ailleurs je vous ai
jamais mis là je sais que vous n'êtes
pas fort alors non alors y'a pas de bébé
à l'horizon quand les roues hier alaric
antoine qui a parlé de vous regarder tu
m'a pas déçu une seconde tu es le
seigneur des anneaux aujourd'hui
mon précieux je sais pas s'il vient
c'est rigolo muji leverdez mais en tout
cas je souhaitais pour y tiendrait pas
devant telle enquête compare à gollum
c'est gentil
comment ça passe un pacte mais attendez
attendez à ce que la photo de gilles
verdez bébé aulas on l'a on parle à
calais et vous allez voir
[Applaudissements]
des mines et même à son âge il fait un
coup de pression juste de basket
messieurs on fait un peu il ya d'autres
enfants qui regardent
[Rires]